منذ أن بدأنا في قيادة السيارات ،
حلمنا أن سياراتنا ستقودنا يومًا ما
على بعد خمسة كيلومترات - أنت الآن
تحت السيطرة التلقائية على
التوجيه الذي لم تحدث الثورة
بدلاً من ذلك ، كان هناك
تقدم تدريجي مثل التحكم في
التطواف التكيفي مع مغادرة المسار
المساعدة في الإنذار والوقوف في عام 1956
، هكذا اعتقدت جنرال موتورز أننا سنقود
20 عامًا فقط على الطريق ،
لكننا في النهاية
هنا كلنا على
ما يرام ، ها هي عجلة القيادة
وها هي يدي على فنجان القهوة الخاص بي
الآن من فضلك لا تحاول ذلك في نظام Tesla
Cadillac الذي تم إعداده بالفعل
للتأكد من أنه يمكنني رفع يدي
عن عجلة القيادة في أي مكان أريدهما
أن يكونا لفترات طويلة من الوقت
لفترات طويلة جدًا إذا احتجت
لتولي هذا الضوء هنا في
غرفة عجلة القيادة سوف يتحول من الأخضر
إلى الأحمر
وستعلمني النغمة أنني بحاجة إلى إمساك عجلة
القيادة والبدء في القيادة حتى ذلك الحين
يمكنني الاستمتاع  يعتمد
نظام كاديلاك سوبر كروز في الوقت الحالي
على خرائط مفصلة ثلاثية الأبعاد مخزنة في
ذاكرة السيارات ، ويقتصر استخدامه على
الطرق السريعة الرئيسية ، فهو يستشعر
السيارات من حوله باستخدام الرادار والكاميرات ،
وقد نسيت تقريبًا وجود
كاميرا أخرى فوقها  عجلة القيادة التي
تراقبني أن الكاميرا موجودة
للتأكد من أن عيني على الطريق
لأن هذه لا تزال تعتبر
ميزات مساعدة للسائق ، ولا
تعتبر القيادة الذاتية مع
supercruise جنرال موتورز متحفظة إلى حد ما ،
على سبيل المثال فازت هذه السيارة '
لتغيير الممرات بالنسبة لك مثل البعض الآخر ،
فهل لا يثق مهندسو جنرال موتورز في هذه
المستشعرات لأخذ السيارة إلى أي مكان
لم يتم توجيه وجهك إليه بالفعل ،
وتذكر الآن تلك الكاميرا التي ذكرت تلك الكاميرا
المثبتة على عجلة القيادة والتي
تراقب وجهي  مع التأكد من أنني
لا أفعل هذا لفترة طويلة وأنظر بعيدًا
عن الطريق ، فأنا أتحدث معك باستمرار
بدلاً من أن يتوقف الأمر بعد فترة
، ونفعل ذلك ، فلنواجه أنا  الغالبية
العظمى من حوادث السيارات ناتجة عن
البشر ، فلن يمر وقت طويل قبل
أن تصبح أجهزة الكمبيوتر أفضل بكثير مما نحن عليه
حتى ذلك الحين اقتربتنا شركة جنرال موتورز
خطوة
أخرى [موسيقى]